what can i say i
got a positive covet test for antibodies
and i had to talk to dr drew about this
when i had it before
and then i recovered even though i never
had any symptoms i never felt slightly
sick
let's talk to dr drew immediately ladies
and gentlemen
dr drew hey guys how are you
very welcome thank you good to see you
guys your
first guest that we've had on twice so
far
i'm i am privileged to be that guest
yeah and
uh here you know scott randolph you'll
also
hear uh paul briskey chiming in every
once in a while
he's uh not in your view but um
but i met paul i met paul when when you
guys were out here right
um yeah the doctor's office when we did
the aids test
yeah right how are you drew oh my god
thank you good to see you yeah nice to
see you
steve steve and i have a long nefarious
road together my goodness
yeah okay you're like it's just doesn't
narrow it down
he's like we all have our dr drew mugs
yeah oh nice thank you for that every
single one of us has a different dr drew
mug right now
look at that there's you me and bob
forrest and you're happy
that's right okay so so diving right
into it i wanted to talk to you again
because
our first podcast we recorded before the
pandemic
set in yeah and we haven't been able to
discuss that at all
and since i've had a multiple tests for
covid19
and my antibodies test was positive
indicating that i've previously had
covid19
but since recovered from it and so
what does that mean do you let me before
i answer that
do you remember any illness or exposure
i don't remember ever even feeling
slightly sick
were you coming around somebody with
covid were you
did you have any known exposure not that
i'm not
nothing known whatsoever all right so so
the all of our testing is imperfect
right now there's lots of
false negatives and false positives but
you had
sort of the gold standard for the
antibody you had both the igg and the
igm test
and your idg was positive and you know
that you know that because i shared my
actual
test results with you i sent screenshots
i saw the price saw the printout
and and it's more mine is more reliable
because it was uh from a blood test is
that right
right and even those have a lot of a
fair number of false ever false
positives but but i i
generally i think we can rely on those
and it's also interesting that you had
just the igg which means that you were
exposed to it at some time in the past
not recently um and you've also you're
also
there are things that they can do with
those igg immunoglobulins they can for
instance do
viral neutralizing tests to see if that
those
immunoglobulins that they found will
neutralize other coronavirus
which i'm assuming they do as part i
don't know this for a fact but i'm
assuming they do it
as part of the run up to uh the
the giving of convalescing plasma which
i know you're doing as well right
right yeah i found out about forget how
i found out but i
i learned that people who have recovered
from kovid covid19 and
have antibodies can donate their plasma
to help very sick people is
but i also heard that that's like some
like
some like 1800 [ __ ] that it is ship but
it worked then and it still works now
it's not high
tech it's an old-school approach in fact
when it first came up uh a lot of us
were just like oh really we're gonna do
that but it has shown to have some
use so what is it really helping people
well it sounds like
kind of the concept of a vaccine where
the vaccine you take the actual disease
put it in their body and so that they
can get it and recover from it
like i've got the actual disease in my
body and we can give it to somebody by
the same sort of
philosophy exactly it's it's like giving
you the same thing as a vaccine but that
happened in somebody else's body
right and because we don't have yet a
vaccine or we haven't distributed a
vaccine
all we have is people who've actually
recovered from the the infection itself
which is wonderful i mean i had a guy
that was very very sick and i wanted to
get him
convalescent plasma this was earlier in
the pandemic
and uh back then you actually had to
match
a person up with a donor in order to get
it for them and this
gentleman unfortunately passed away
while we were screwing around trying to
get it to
go and it you know it's a reminder that
if you're older this is an older person
and if you have the risk factors this
thing is just brutal it just goes fast
it just could be awful
but by the same token there are plenty
of people like steve out there that
had it didn't even know they had it
right but what's confusing for me
is that i tested negative paul tested
negative
and his fiancee texted negative and
we're all around steve 24
7 and i'm even surprised that his
fiancee tested negative
because you know they're always [ __ ]
we've seen the pictures
[Laughter]
and we just the pictures of you guys
naked i don't know what that's right
the rest of it um but uh
it sort of suggests that perhaps you
were exposed some time ago which is
an interesting theory by itself right
now why your
your fiance wouldn't have it i i don't
quite know
it again there's a lot we don't know
about this virus and it always whenever
i hear stories of this i think could it
be a false positive is it
i mean i i'm that's one of the reasons
i'm glad you're giving the plasma
that will really work you up to make
sure you actually have the antibody
right right i mean they're not gonna
waste their time if it's not there
so this is good i'm glad you're doing
that and if you have it you will help
somebody
for real for sure as much as i would
like to to help people
i'm equally motivated to just get to the
bottom of what my actual
status is good that's fine whatever
motivates me yeah win win
it's win-win all the way and if you have
if you indeed have the enemy globulin
you are for the
intermediate term you seem to be immune
which is
an amazing thing i'm very jealous and i
i signed up for to be a human subject in
the phase 3
vaccine trials because first of all i
want to be human subject i'm going to do
whatever i can
and secondly i want that vaccine as soon
as i can possibly get it and it
the the technology is just exceptional
so i'm ready to go
right i i hope i hope you do get that
and so so now of course i found out
about the
the donating plasma to help very sick
people
i asked you about that you said go to
redcrossblood.org which i did
right there on the front page it said
have you recovered from covid19 and you
know to sign up for this uh
convalescent plasma program which is
what we're talking about
i clicked that right away they had a
very short questionnaire
you know have you uh tested this and
that but then
it when it came to the question of when
was your last symptoms
there was no option for me to answer
honestly because i never had symptoms so
i just kind of plugged in
uh february of this year just because
because that kind of reflected what your
explanation was
yeah and and i submitted my form like
that
then um i guess it took uh two days
maybe one day this morning i woke up to
an email from the red cross saying
we need more information regarding your
last symptoms
and i responded with thank you for
asking you gave me no option to say that
i was asymptomatic
but now that now that you're asking for
more information i've attached both my
antibodies test and my follow-up nasal
swab test
so hopefully they can you know like
glean from that that i'm a complete and
i described you as my doctor without
naming you i said according to my doctor
this is this indicates that i'm the
perfect candidate for your program
these results which i've attached yeah
yeah
yeah well hopefully that's true i mean i
hope that they will take you because
it's
it's it's a literally a lifesaver
somebody's really a lifesaver
my question is so say if steve does have
the antibodies
can he spread it if he comes into
contact with
somebody that does have it i've said it
before and i'll say it again
being bros with the world's most famous
doctor
rules and you know what else rules
coffee
you might notice i drink it every single
episode the whole time
and i don't feel bad about that because
i don't
ever drink it without very
quality ingredients as my creamer i use
layered superfood creamer every time
and i'm terrified of running out of it
that's why i have so much
plus i personally purchased every single
one of these bags
i literally love it so much made by the
legend
laird hamilton they got all kinds of
cool flavors
here's original it's fantastic they got
cacao i'm almost out of that
tumeric it comes with functional
mushrooms if you want
man these are really top quality
ingredients
that make me feel great and again i
don't feel bad about drinking
so much coffee so if you want to try
this out which i really recommend
because it is
so delicious go to layeredsuperfood.com
use the promo code stevo and get 20
off your order plus free shipping you
got to do it now
right for 20 off your order and free
shipping
go to layeredsuperfood.com and use the
promo code stevo
you are going to love this stuff
now let's get back to drew no it means i
can't
get infected yeah that's it there there
but it's got you you're actually asking
a very rather sophisticated question
which is which is is which is the
difference between
being infected and getting the illness
right so you could get infected and not
get the illness or you could not get
infected
and the antibody response we believe you
have will mean you
do not get infected and we're trying to
look for a vaccine
that prevents infection for the very
reason you're bringing up because if
people can get infected
they can produce virus and they can
infect other people who might get the
disease
so for laymen that means that
coronavirus
is the virus but covid19
is the disease and those are two
different virus
the virus is technically called sars
coronavirus ii
uh and and it's a relative of the myrrhs
and the previous sars one except that
those two illnesses
had i think mers was 35 fatality rate
and coronavirus was like an 18 or 20
fatality rate so they were much more
dangerous right
now you said something earlier i had a
guy and and you described this this
patient for people who don't know
what you're saying is you had an actual
patient
people think of you as a celebrity as a
guy on tv they don't understand that you
have an actual practice that you've got
an
office patients come to see you and
uh so that's where we did your aids test
or whatever we did
right my office yeah and what tragic
news he said that uh
you know this guy and and he died
yeah yeah and he checked every box in
terms of risk factors and so i have
witnessed firsthand
the difference i've also had a number of
people who have had mild cases i've had
now i'm looking at you with asymptomatic
cases
i've had older patients with some
moderately severe cases
and i've seen people that check every
box and when you check all the boxes and
you're older
it is crazy brutal but
that's not to say that that young people
are off the hook because
what i you know read or learned
there are young people whose immune
systems are strong enough to fight off
the respiratory symptoms
but that just makes them hang in there
for uh strokes and
heart attacks like we're having it's not
that simple it's not that simple uh
but let's remind ourselves that if
you're under 40 the fatality rate is
between
0.3 percent like 0.03
0.003 and 0.8 right it's a
very small number of people to get into
trouble but when there are millions of
people infected
even that small number translates into
thousands right
uh so the primary risk factor that that
i have observed that the press really
kind of talking about
uh in in youth is obesity
if you're obese it can go bad can you
define
obese because i've gained a little bit
of weight over the last
couple years if you look at me am i am i
obese
i don't think so i again i i am not a
huge fan of ideal body weight sort of
data
i think it doesn't take into account
muscularity and body types and all kinds
of things i mean there are plenty of
people that
you know i mean a lot of wwe wrestlers
are obese right but if you if you just
do
body weight you know and those sorts of
measurements
he's being very gentle with you scott
yeah no no you i've not seen somebody
similar to scott get really sick i've
not seen that i can't get it
um now now early on as i followed the
news around
coronavirus i felt that you know looking
towards
italy made the most sense because they
were ahead of us in in what was
happening whatever's going on in italy
you know we're we were a few weeks
behind and it's been
months since i saw this uh this story
out of italy where a doctor said
i'm looking at this virus and it has
become considerably weaker
when uh when i analyze a sample of it
the viral load
is much smaller this virus has become
much less
deadly and and i thought wow i look over
i've
not seen that kind of reporting on the
american side
but it seems to add up with all of the
cases
skyrocketing yet the death toll not
skyrocketing
are we looking at a virus that has
become weaker
that that's i i'm not sure i can answer
that question with great clarity
except to say the only thing we do know
that has changed for sure
is that it has modified itself in some
such a way as to make it
more infectious but no one knows whether
it actually
is more infectious if that makes sense
so the
so the virologists are telling us that
there's been some changes in the biology
that are associated with more
infectivity
but we don't know yet whether or not yet
that's actually resulted in
a greater degree of spread in terms of
the virus weakening
i remember that data coming out of italy
we had high hopes for it here it never
bore fruit
it really seems to be more the result of
people protecting themselves and more
vulnerable people getting infected in
the earlier stages of the
of the uh epidemic if that makes sense
and and but to bring his interesting
point
to to look towards italy as our model
i thought from the beginning and it's
pretty clear now in retrospect huge
mistake
well not a huge mistake a a relative
we are not and we're not italy we're not
uh
italy the predominant uh degree of the
predominant patient there was
over 80. they have a much higher
percentage of elderly patients there
they have a very different kind of
health care system
and they were not able to meet the needs
which was one of the dramatic aspects
i knew that we would flex that we would
improvise that our system would meet the
demands of whatever happened the
epidemic so that was
number one why i knew we were different
and secondly we
we have a different age distribution it
was affecting different people still
killing older people
but affecting more in different age
groups okay do you think it's wise to
open
orlando disneyland disney world disney
world
you know the the head of the cdc just
said today and i
agree with this completely that if we
had universal
mask and physical distancing this thing
would be
markedly under control in two to four
weeks that
whether or not you closed or opened
anything it's
about wearing the mask wearing them
properly staying six feet apart
you i the whole idea of cl to show me
where there's evidence
that a nail salon is where povet is
coming from
there's no evidence for that and yet
they've closed the nail salons
another story today the story i think it
was out of florida
two hair stylists active disease
got sick and exposed 139 clients
to the to the virus known exposure
you know what the transmission rate was
everybody was wearing masks
in the in the salon the transmission
rate was
zero wow zero
masks work even with up close contact
like hair cutting
so come on everybody we're squandering
an opportunity here
by not wearing masks i understand it's
pain in the ass i understand it's
uncomfortable i understand the
government's been asking you do all
kinds of [ __ ] you don't want to do
don't draw the line at the max that's a
huge huge tattoo okay
i've got a question i'm dying to ask
because i i
i've been wearing the mask like a very
good boy but it is so annoying like it
said
it gets hot it like the even the con
the concern about a lot of carbon
dioxide toxicity by by
stifling the oxygen so i thought
and i want to know what you think about
this is it a a good
solution for me to go ahead and buy
a portable oxygen tank with an oxygen
mask so that i've got like like oxygen
but like like the athletes right
so i've got this this delicious oxygen
like at the oxygen bar
and then that's gonna make it so my face
isn't hot and uh
and i'm not getting lots of carbon
dioxide
i wasn't even ready for dr drew's
reaction to my
oxygen idea but before you witness it
let me tell you i'm a 46 year old man
okay and i've struggled with my weight
in the past
but i've been eating sensibly i've been
active exercising and i think i look
pretty good
for a guy in his late 40s and you know
what i'm determined to show off the bod
and i want it to look good and that's
why i'm taking care of my grooming needs
with manscape that's right i just
take care of my balls with my lawnmower
3.0
oh yeah why not with my new shears
2.0 these quality stainless steel
nail taking care of devices
oh yeah and be careful with that
uh nose hair that happens and when you
get a little older ear here
i got i got it all under control it's
summertime baby
and i'm looking my best you can look
your best too
by going to manscaped.com and using the
promo code stevo
for 20 off your order and free shipping
that's right
20 off your order and free shipping you
go to manscape.com
use the promo code stevo see if you can
look as good as i do
yeah now go get that answer from drew
don't you have to be careful about
breathing in 100 o2
all day like pneumonia like that's what
happens
it literally damages your lung the o2
becomes a free radical and damages the
lungs
right you need some carbon dioxide
correct well
you're asking complicated questions in
reality this is a complicated podcast
my first thought is steve you have
access to too many resources
this is options that other people don't
think about but good for you
uh number one number number two um the
whole idea of co2 accumulation is
totally bogus
the only way you accumulate co2 is when
your lungs don't work right and that is
a
that is a certain subset of advanced
emphysema get hypercapnia
other people do not now if you're doing
a triathlon
okay yes you could accommodate some co2
and it could make an issue
for i don't care how hard you're working
out you're not going to get hyper
uh okay how about if i get a tank
full of just regular air that's called
the environment
you just want to be like bane from back
why would you do that why would you do
that just to look cool
no said that uh so that i can breathe
better with the mask on i want the mask
to actually supply me regular air yeah
yeah i i'm betting you could find a mask
that you will like
i've been i bought so many of them i've
been i've tried so many and i keep
ordering more and i keep ordering more
but don't worry i'm going to keep
ordering them and when i find the one
that
actually works perfect i'm going to buy
a bunch and sell them
good man i like that so so so
let me just tell you that the bandana
you know single layer cloth
probably not very good the virus doesn't
just
float into the air and get through the
virus travels on
droplets from our speaking and singing
and coughing
and it's the droplets that do not get
through the mask
that prevent us from getting exposed to
the virus
um i i had a bandana tied around my face
just yesterday and and my fiancee luck
said
oh that's not effective that's not very
helpful she says
and she said come over here and and with
the bandana breathe on me and i went
over and i tried to blow on her and she
said oh i didn't feel anything maybe it
is good
did you have it done it's better than
nothing
it's better than nothing but it's not as
effective as a double double fly mask
is it controversial among doctors and
like scientists of why
there's been a like a the the virus has
increased over the last couple
couple weeks like why is it there there
isn't because i mean
everybody knows what it is we've all
been moving about
we've you know we've sort of opened
things up and moving about
and we started congregating in the
streets by the tens of thousands without
masks or you know whether yelling and
screaming in the streets
and of course i mean if that didn't
cause transmission
then we never should have locked down in
the first place you're talking about the
protest
of course of course you'd congregate in
in close environments even out of doors
it's going to cause some transmission
and then you continue to transmit by
going to bars and going out to places
of course that's going to transmit some
more now the question
now we have to face now is
how much do we risk letting the genie
out of the bottle
and how much can we tolerate in terms of
our sort of daily disease burden
um but again and if we wore mass again
the cdc director today just told us
it would really dramatically be under
control dramatically
and in the states where things are
really accelerating it's where they were
refusing to wear masks and
i don't know if you have you guys been
to bars since they opened the bars up
there right now
we went to some bars back when it was
open and i was
uncomfortable super close people were
and how people will come up to you and
are they're loud and talking they've
been drinking i'm
literally susan grabbed me at one point
and pulled me away from somebody it's
like
there's an epidemic going on what are
you doing and so
i i bars and the muse there's music and
so people are talking loud which again
is more
droplets coming out and so i i
definitely think there's no doubt about
why this was happening and
you know here we are so is it more
because i read a times uh magazine
article that said
um it had nothing to do with the protest
it was about restaurants opening up
but i'm like if it had nothing to do
with the protest then
then why are we locking down that
doesn't make any logical sense at all of
course it had something
there had to have been transmission had
to have been the trump rally had
transmission
the demonstration temperature just the
way it is it's okay
it may be worth the risk that's fine if
we say it's worth the risk
no problem but let's not let's not
delude ourselves that that
it's impossible that nothing to do with
people standing side by side by the
thousands tens of thousands
of course that has to create traffic
okay yeah is the air
on airplanes clean and do you think
flying is safe it's recirculated about
every seven to eight minutes
and again the masks should do the trick
i had heard that the
um incidence of uh covet in
flight attendants and pilots is
exceedingly low
maybe even zero again i don't have
confirmation of that but very low
which is pretty reassuring about plane
flight
are you still thinking about running for
governor in l.a
i i am not another group came around and
tried to get me to run for
mayor and for about 10 minutes i thought
oh my god that may be the only way
that i can actually get something done
with the homeless problem which is going
to
spiral out of control going forward here
i mean it's just
it's just insane what's happening and
what's going to happen and
i know exactly how to fix it it's not a
simple problem i mean it's not it's not
that complex a problem it's the
population i've been serving for decades
i know how to treat this group and what
we should do with them
um and i said the first thing we should
do is stop coming calling it
homelessness because you call it
homelessness that suggests that if you
give them a home you've solved the
problem
no this is not homelessness this is open
air asylum
this is drug addiction this is much more
serious stuff
friend of mine is involved in the
project room key
which is where they give hotel rooms to
the homeless folk
and he was going oh you know you could
be one paycheck away from being homeless
too i thought oh really okay
well what else besides uh the room what
else are they doing for all the people
in the hotel
well they um they get lots of services i
go really lots of services
huh oh yeah a psychiatric nurse comes
every day a psychiatrist comes two times
a week a social work comes by three
times a week
oh really so if i lost my job that would
suddenly
require me to see a psychiatrist every
every day at a psychiatric nurse that's
what i would need just because i lost my
job
no they what they're running is a
residential psychiatric facility which
is what's needed
which is exactly what they should be
doing but let's not mince words on
on the rhetoric around this let's just
let's just build these facilities
or arrange these facilities and get
people into them the problem is you
can't get people into them
uh and and or they reject the services
once they get in and
then you can't do a damn thing so uh
after about a a few minutes of thinking
all that through i thought
uh am i insane i don't want to be mayor
what are we talking about here
yeah but i still am very very worried
about this problem is it rude of me to
to not want to know what hotel they're
staying in
because i would be worried about
catching like coronavirus or something
like that from
yes it would be rude of you number one
and i'm sorry i hadn't asked
in number two um homeless had very low
incidence of corona
very low incidence which is kind of
interesting why
well you thought before because it was
outside right and there was very low
outdoor transmission
the vast fast ass majority of
transmission is indoor
which is why when people talk about uh
isolating and place and all this stuff i
think
you're gonna put people back inside with
the virus what there's no
science to substantiate that i know it
makes common sense
but if you're also telling me that 50
000 people in the street
doesn't cause transmission how can you
then lock people in rooms where we know
it happens
in china they did this big study and
they found that
that only one outdoor transmission could
they find and it's a relatively
one-to-one type transmission while if
it's indoors it's one to three
so you're better off outdoors you are
better off outdoors
it happens but it's less likely to
happen outdoors do you think you need to
wear a mask if you're
like going for a jog or walking your dog
i do
i i do it mostly as a gesture right
it's a as a as a not to you know be
polite to other people
and as if you're running again walking
the dog is different if you're if you're
away from other people then
take the mask off but but if you are you
know within 20 feet or something and you
might get within six feet then maybe
when running you're exerting yourself as
you go by and you could leave a trail of
stuff maybe 25 or 50 feet behind you so
put the mask on why
why it's it's to me it's it's a nod it's
it's it's an acknowledgement
that i'm protecting the other people all
right we're done with coronavirus yeah
and except to say that we we all thought
it was
absolutely commendable just
we admire you so much for your uh
your acknowledgement that you initially
got some certain stuff around about the
coronavirus wrong
we were just saying like if only uh if
only the world was full of people who
were able to admit that they got
something wrong
so i i think thank you for saying that
and uh
he i did not get the infectivity and the
ferociousness and the in the at-risk
group those are the two things i did not
get but it's interesting
now i was doing a lot of comparison with
h1n1
which i had back in 2009 and it was
horrible and nearly killed me
um and that was i think it is that right
that was a flu
swine flu that's why and that one killed
000 people and infected between half a
million half a billion and a billion
people and i think it is instructive to
look back at that
pandemic now just to look at how we felt
about it then
versus how we feel about this one now it
kind of calms you down a little bit
because nearly 600 000 people died and
you didn't even
you don't even know what happened you're
not even aware of it
it was a story on the news every night
but it was not the craziness we're
we're experiencing with this thing and
so i i think we
under reacted to that one i think we're
overreacting to this one
and sort of a sane middle ground is
probably where we all ought to keep
ourselves emotional
all right so now we switch gears
are you familiar drew with chloroprocane
spinal this is
man
sounds like he's familiar okay so
procaine
is sort of a relative of xylocaine and
it's a spinal
anesthetic right so you're going to
you're going to be paralyzed from your
waist down
right exactly this is
an injection that goes into your spinal
canal
and it is a local anesthetic that which
would paralyze my legs completely
for roughly 45 minutes
and not just paralyze you also won't
feel anything in your legs
so we can do stuff to your legs right
that sounds fun
okay so as you might recall and here i
am giving away creative
the people who hang in for this podcast
to the you know to the very end they
really get the goods
and and you'll you'll remember i had the
idea that i wanted to ride a bicycle
while having general anesthesia drugs
administered
such that i would go completely
unconscious and crash the bike and it
would be hilarious
while we tried remember right we tried
it
and uh and and and the thing was that uh
automate a date was the drug we used
everyone was what's the one that pro
they'd say they said don't use propofol
because it's a substance of abuse
but etomidate is not uh characterized
as pleasant by any standard and
and that nobody would ever use it for
fun so we used to accommodate i felt
very comfortable going through with
using automate
but yeah my experience was i found it
very pleasant i really liked it
and it was upsetting for me i was like
oh no i can't do that anymore
so then uh so so and and and we've we
failed to knock me out with automate
so i've got this whole bit which i
picture as an
episode of a bucket list series and it
has no
ending so that i i've
met somebody who is a medical
professional they will remain
anonymous they will be in disguise are
they in this kind are they in this
country
we're not going to tell you i'm not even
going to tell you that we might be are
they
are they going to do it in this country
whatever this thing is i'm not even
going to
tell you that okay but i've been suffice
to say they are
absolutely a medical professional and uh
they said that they will
that they'll administer the shot into my
spinal canal
and they'll have an iv you'll be
impressed by this they said we'll want
to have an iv
in case i need to give you meds to
raise your blood pressure because the
chloroprokane might lower my blood
pressure
so they're going to monitor that so you
know they're very professional
they say it's totally safe you forgot to
tell us that yesterday
so is this an anesthesiologist because
that would be
the reason i'm asking is it is i want
somebody not just with experience with
the procaine and the blood pressure
issue but also with airways
and anesthesiologists are very good at
managing airways right
yeah so there's the potential for airway
stuff
even though it's only my lower half yeah
but sometimes it starts to drift up
it's you you want it low but sometimes
it will kind of get up and if it gets
into your diaphragm we got a problem
okay so what people don't understand
that that are listening or watching is
that like
i have to set this up right i have to
like figure out the ambulance
and and i didn't hear that yesterday and
i was like well let's talk to dr drew
about that my concern
is that like if something were to happen
we're all [ __ ] right like steve's dead
and and like i go worst case scenario am
i right to do that
or is it not that well you're right to
worry about i mean you want to you want
to keep him
safe but i think he's talking about
legal experience reliability i mean
that's a legal question that i hate to
even think about
i mean it's going to be fine but it's
like that's what he says oh don't worry
about it they'll be fine
it's going to be fine is this person an
anesthesiologist
yes okay so so you can have a certain
degree of i mean that's the person who's
really
responsible okay for this whole thing
right yeah
and so and there's a million ways to
go past some what are you going to do
while you're under spinal
i i'm going to have one of these uh
neck braces so i can't break my neck
when i fall
right like the one the race the race car
drivers use i'm gonna have a race car
helmet
with the camera pointed back so you can
see my face
i'd like to have a straight jacket on so
i can't have my
arms help out in any situation and
probably walking on stilts
i think your arms would help not break
your spine if you like
no no no no no i'll have my straight
jacket on i'll be walking on stilts
and then they can shoot it into my back
and and uh
i'll see how far i can walk like uh
gotta be cool if we had two of us that
we could race to see who could walk
farthest on stilts but
when you when you collapse you won't
collapse in a sort of
normal way you'll just you'll flop
and you can dislocate your hip and break
your leg all kinds of things can break
you know i'm just worried about his neck
what if they're what if they're only
drywall stilts which put my feet just
four feet off the ground
[Laughter]
i know better than to get out of them
it just scares the hell out of me yeah
my i think i think my concern
is that uh his airway
like he'll go unconscious and he'll be
unresponsive or
if he falls i don't want him to be
paralyzed by
by breaking his neck or hitting his head
and like having this
whatever and i don't understand and i
don't understand how this guy is going
to keep all the spinal stuff
i mean it's a tube they stick in there
and then they administer
i don't quite understand how that's all
going to work um
it's not just he's gonna pull all the
equipment out and then put you up on the
stilts but you're gonna be paralyzed
already ah
yeah how long does it take to kick in i
don't think it's
long yeah i think it's about a minute
maybe it's minutes yeah i think it's
about one i think
about thinking about how xylocaine works
if you you're trying to numb your teeth
up or something
right so okay um so
i'm uh on some some uh
seated thing which which allows me to
just just
pop up like at like standing up out of a
chair
and uh it's so that we all rig it up so
then once the tube's in
and i assume he's gonna have a like a
plunger kind of a syringe type deal
so when he plunges plunge and i stand up
right away and start walking to see how
far i can go in one minute
okay that sort of makes a little more
sense than than that's with stills what
if you were just like doing a
a bike and you watched your legs kind of
fly off you know as they became
paralyzed
ah tricycle or a unicycle
but it's less funny because you can
still just kind of coast without using
your legs on a bike
i think running i mean if you're just on
a stationary bike yeah
i'm just trying to think of ways to not
fall
yeah should i have an ambulance there
with like
o2 and breathing stuff or this guy i
i this guy should have a whole cart you
should have an anesthesia cart
handy okay what i'm hearing dr drew say
is that we've got a real ender that
we've got a a grand
finale you know if anything like uh
i i'll have to say it for steve is he's
one of the most positive guys
i've ever met and like i'm one of the
most negative because i'm always going
to worst case scenario and he's like so
what i hear
is we're go for next guy
is a tuesday guy that is just to steve
doing whatever the [ __ ] he wants to do
like i said i've learned longer not to
talk him out of things
what about an epidural that pregnant
women do like what's that difference
because doesn't that just like an
epidural doesn't that numb you
yeah same kind of thing but it's not
going to travel up their spine and
um again you have to have an
anesthesiologist
all these different kinds of know spinal
anesthesias
you know they're different for different
things he he's going for a total
paralysis which is different than what
they're going for during childbirth
obviously how did you vet this guy
he just said hi i'm an anesthesiologist
and you're like sold
i met him during a meet and greet after
one of my shows
okay you know he's legit yep okay
now and steve said oh dude you're an
anesthesiologist i want to do something
rad
what can we do this guy brainstormed
with you didn't he
wow his idea at my show
he he witnessed the bit about the
anesthesia bike ride
and uh he came up to me and he said hey
i've got an i've got a potential way for
you to get this
this concluded
[Music]
yeah i feel like drew is the voice of
reason yeah i want me
i try
are you doing podcasts in person these
days
i i am with corolla and then susan
started me doing a stream every day out
of this
room um and that has kind of kept me
engaged through this whole quarantine
thing i i
generally am depressed i don't like any
of this i feel like my life's been taken
away from me
we like traveling we were going to go do
some stuff what's that susan
oh it's just you promote the shows so i
do a show called the dose of doctor drew
everyday
at doctordrew.com also at facebook and
at doctor.tv
right did i get it all okay she's
standing back and then we do a call-in
show once a week where
called ask dr drew same same format here
but we actually take phone calls and um
and i just
might we started out essentially just
trying to calm everybody down
so i just sort of go through what's of
you know we what we can see today about
the cova and chronovirus just trying to
interpret the data
because i i know when i listen to the
news i can't tell what's going on i
can't i get scared it's
are you i can't tell what the truth is
so i just try to sit down and look at
the data and talk about it
and we have a lot of interesting people
that interact with me who are also
experts and give me good information and
things and so we you know
just kind of shared share ideas here all
right that's cool
i maybe have one last question for you
and steve and i had a long conversation
about it and we even
dragged his dad into it and i think it'd
be interesting to hear your take on it
because you probably get asked so many
times for favors and to do things
and steve can probably like like
assemble this better than i can
because just he's a better speaker for
some reason but uh
go ahead okay i i went up to a guy one
time i needed uh
a speaker for a meeting and uh this guy
knew could speak for me and i said hey
man
how you doing uh you know what do you
and then what are you up to tonight
and then he said i'm not doing anything
and i said oh cool because i got this
meeting and i need a speaker
and he goes yeah what's with the small
talk why don't you just get to the point
you clearly want a favor why don't you
you know like it's kind of insulting you
wouldn't just say hey i need a favor
you know and uh and i'll never forget
that and it changed the way i approach
people
when i when i want a favor i always
think of that but then scott
said he was running a business and he
had a guy who was a mentor and he needed
some advice
and so he said i just to the mentor
hey man what i need some advice in this
and and
his experience was the guy said oh since
you uh
forgot about the niceties of uh you know
interacting you know i i i'll tell you
you know i'm doing okay just got out of
heart surgery you know like
maybe ask how you're doing so it's like
there are these two different situations
you can't win how do you prefer to be
asked
i i don't like a long story leading up
to the ask
you know what i mean i don't want a tale
of whoa that's sort of setting me
setting the table
for a for a question for whatever when
you know it's coming yeah
i i i'd rather just get to the
get to the ask now i i think nice cities
are just sort of generally a good idea i
think we generally just make contact
with people before you
go hey man i need something from you uh
so i'm generally
in the in favor of some niceties but i
don't like the
the long roll-up i have a quick question
yeah so well so drew i've been a fan of
yours for a long time i've been a fan of
steve's for a long time
and we've always heard you know steve's
dad
ted glover oh yeah how did you meet ted
like how do you know ted
okay before i answer that my wife's back
you're doing doing uh
jumping jacks what do you want me to say
oh i forgot to podcast to mention i do a
podcast called after dark
with christina p dr after dark uh
and adam and i do a podcast most days uh
called the admin dr drew show so
check those out as well thank you honey
and uh
ted ted
i believe my first um one person was
i love this huh the first time you met
that in person
i i was checking into rehab no oh no
that's right i believe i i believe the
first time was in a limousine
on the way to right yeah the jackass
number two
premiere yes it was i'm completely wrong
okay
to go to the jackass number two red
carpet premiere
i had my sister my dad
my my at the time four-year-old niece
uh and ron jeremy and dr drew
in the limo yeah
the world's most famous doctor and the
world's most famous porn star
my four-year-old niece and my dad and my
sister and i got out of the limo
because they're my girlfriends
i got out of the limo waltz down to the
red carpet
pulled my wiener out and peed all over
the red carpet with everybody snapping
all the photos the full red carpet deal
weiner out fully peeing my dad was here
in that in that situation ted and i were
drawn to one another
that was when you connected you found
solace
and i think i remember talking to him at
length
at the pool at the um after party yeah
rosa at the roosevelt the hollywood
roosevelt right
uh and that same pool where like whitney
houston was last seen
loaded before just before she died right
it's that same area
because i remember seeing that picture
going oh i remember that i was there
with steven's dad
crazy and i immediately and your dad of
course gave me a bunch of
recommendations for reading
yeah he gave me and he sent me some
books and so we and we communicated by
email
and uh yeah we had a little relationship
going and then i met him again with you
guys right okay so you guys bonded at
the jackass 2 premiere so it's through
steve that you do know each other it's
not like
separate from steve you guys met correct
yeah yeah but though i could see that i
mean i i ted is definitely kind of guy
would go
toward i mean just such an interesting
dude and the
not not the guy you you
steve and ted i you you you know i get
that i get them now they know them both
but you would not
put pick them both out of a lineup as
father and son right that's hilarious
yeah i'm always interested in like
because when i was doing drugs and and
i never wanted anybody to see it like
let alone like i would drink in front of
my mom or my dad or something but
like when you're in the limo going to a
party it's jackassing are you like
are you just drinking beer are you
snacking coke in front of people or are
you doing whip
like what i i had been inhaling nitrous
oxide that entire day to the exclusion
of
air in front of you
get your oxygen
but people normally for whatever reason
hide their [ __ ] from me
and so i was not aware of what was going
on with him but i knew he was not
i knew he was not straight did you ever
do that stuff in front of your dad steve
ah no okay no i mean i would drink in
front of my dad but i wouldn't even
smoke pot or anything so in the limo
you're just probably drinking and like
just thinking about the next time you're
gonna do a fat whip it
pretty much yeah he was very happy in
that limo
he was he he announced to all of us that
this was a dream come true for him
and i was privileged to make his dream
come true for him
i don't know that i've got any footage
or photos from inside that limo but i
i am truly touched that our friendship
drew
has lasted for for so long i mean i've
known drew for
for damn near damn near 20 years
and he's just always been such a a good
friend to me
there was a period when i said uh i i
want
i can't be friends and uh someone's
doctor
you can't be my patient if you're my
friend but i think over the years now
we've finally effectively
broken that rule because when i went to
get the aids test
and we uh and we got it we got a few
other things my ekg we tested my heart
and uh so so we've actually uh
we we're friends and we've we've played
with those boundaries a little bit
it was much more important when you were
in your illness because you can't you
can't
deal with those kinds of things with
dual relationships you just cannot
right so so now it's uh it's yeah
i just i just really love you drew and
and uh thank you you too
if you need it i you said you wanted me
to be the first recurring uh
customer here i was deeply honored and
anything for you guys whatever it is
well and you know likewise all the time
i you know anytime you ever want
uh me on a podcast or or anything else
you know you just uh
just holler your doggy is so cute there
man
yeah she's the best yeah oh my god
yeah well right on drew i think that's
going to do it for us
i'm super grateful and susan thank you
for letting me have drew
up she was happy as long as i promoted
all those different shows
yeah maybe you want to do it one more
time just to make her really happy and
uh
yeah apologies to her no she just said
this she just said i should do it all
again yeah
apologies to susan for trying to uh
steal you on sunday when that was your
your uh your date day i know well it's
our
29th anniversary wow all right so
so bring us out with the plugs for all
of your podcasts
drew okay so it's if you go to
doctor.com or sign up at doctordew.tv
you'll see all the different podcasts
there
the the ones we're really interested in
you taking a look at are the dr dre
after dark podcast with christina p over
at your mom's house
and it's it's sort of a new incarnation
of love line you did you do that one
i did yeah yeah now i just do is
christina p regularly rather than having
special guests
and um and then uh
this stream that we do out of here most
days we like people to show up and be a
part of that
be on the chat and interact somehow that
i feel like that's been
i feel like i am contributing with that
one so uh i felt very um
not useful during a lot of this
quarantine and that helped me feel more
useful so thank you
you know be a part of that please all
right hey cheers drew thank you you're
the best
hey congratulations on this this thing
is this
clearly has evolved your your pod thing
yeah
i dig it i really appreciate i
appreciate that so much man
right andrew all right we'll talk soon
thanks drew all right thank you bye guys
[ __ ] dr drew what a bro yeah
and here we are as usual it's time to
thank you guys for sticking around to
the end of the podcast
my street team and uh i i know that
i want to say about 313
of you received the special link i went
crazy trying to
figure out like on the app i don't know
i got it to 313 of you
i [ __ ] hope you guys loved that [ __ ]
and i
really did help me in figuring out a lot
there was a lot of testing going on
in that and uh i arrived at many
conclusions and and so i want to thank
you
for uh helping get that [ __ ] [ __ ]
ready to rock and roll
and i will see you next week holy [ __ ]
i'm gonna just go ahead and announce
this i'm just gonna
tell you this next week is by far
the dopest podcast that we have done yet
by far yeah